Dr zakya when is the correct and the
best time to break the
fast the best time to break the fast is
as soon as night falls as the Quran says
in Surah Bak CH 2 vers 187 eat and drink
until the white thread of dawn becomes
distinct to you from the black thread
and keep the fast until night
falls the moment you see the sunset that
is the best time that you should break
the fast and there's aith of M wasallam
mentioned inkari volume number three in
the book of fasting Hadith number 1954
where the Beloved Prophet said when you
see the night fall from this side and
the day vanishes from this side and the
disk of the sun sets you have to break
your
fast another Hadi mentioned by Abu PE
with him of s bukari Vol number three
book of fasting chapter number 45 he
said we broke the fast moment we saw
that the sun had set and a beloved
Prophet mhamad wasallam as I mentioned
earlier it's mentioned in volume number
one Hadith number 2835 that a beloved
Prophet said that you should hasten in
breaking your fast and you should delay
your it's mentioned in of alaki Hadith
number 8127 seven that the sahabas the
companions of the Prophet they were the
first to break the fast and they were
the last to have
the it's also mentioned in
Al Hadith number
8125 that Prophet muhi wasallam said
that we prophets have been commanded
that we have to hasten in breaking our
fast and delay our s and keep the right
hand or the left while offering Salah
there are various other Hadith which
specifically mention that we have to
hasten the breaking of the fast it's
mentioned in bukari Vol number three in
the book of fasting Hadith number
1957 that our beloved Prophet said that
my
people will be on the right path till
the time they hasten in Breaking the
fast it further mentioned
inan volume number 8 Hadith number
3510 where the Beloved Prophet wasallam
said that my people will be on the
Sunnah till the time they do not wait
for the stars to break the
fast Prophet wasallam also said it's
mentioned
inan Hadith number
3509 that the Beloved Prophet said that
my religion will be seen till the time
my people they H in Breaking the fast
and not do like the Jews and Christians
who delay the fast so based on all
this we have to realize that we have to
break the fast as early as possible it
is the best immediately